well these are unprecedented
circumstances
and i think everybody is working their
hardest and trying to do their best in
in very difficult circumstances and i
know that that is true of
of gavin williamson as it is of all
members of the government
you know and the big focus is on
getting schools back and open at the
start of next month which you mentioned
earlier incredibly important task i
don't think we should be distracted from
that task now
we need to absolutely um focus on it so
you know in in in very difficult
circumstances
we are trying to make the best decisions
you know these are unprecedented times
and having not having the a level exams
is
unprecedented that that obviously has
led to a whole series of
of challenges and complications you know
we've seen this in
all the different uh governments across
the
across the uk responsible for education
so i think of course it's been a
challenge and we absolutely acknowledge
that but what i can tell you is that all
of us are doing
the level best to try to make the right
judgments in what are difficult
circumstances
i take full responsibility of course i
do for the whole pandemic response in
the health and social care
uh areas for which i'm responsible and
um there's the
uh i'm the guy who's who answers the
questions who's
responsible and accountable to
parliament for these things
in my area so absolutely the question is
what's the best thing for the country
in the case of education we've got to
get the schools back
in two weeks time it's really important
just so important
for children's education that schools
come back
in two weeks time in my case when it
comes to the reforms that i've put in
place for
how we deliver public health policy at a
national level i want to make that
a change because it'll improve our
response to coronavirus
and i take absolute of course i take
full responsibility for it